Nicki Minaj teases some seriously sexy
new music yes barbs get ready for a new
era of Nikki the rapper released a
snippet of what appears to be her new
single sampling Rick James Super Freak
[Music]
[Music]
in the video posted to Nikki's Instagram
she sizzles in a racy Burberry bodysuit
and totally gives us the eyes but it's
the not safe for work lyrics that really
caught our attention
[Music]
he always tell me
[Music]
talk about the ultimate thirst trap and
fans are running up the replays hashtag
nikkiefreaky girl is already a trending
topic ahead of the song's official
release I'm very excited about the
success no surprise that Nikki fans are
more than ready for some new music I
mean it's pretty obvious
yeah this comes on the heels of the
Superstar hitting the stage in London
for wireless Fest of course she pulled
out some gems from her catalog like
super bass and the crowd went wild
[Music]
[Applause]
time
[Applause]
[Applause]
after the show it was a literal Nikki
pandemonium a meet and greet in Camden
had to be canceled due to fans
overcrowding the area just to catch a
glimpse of Mrs Minaj
it's nice to see Nikki returning with
the new sound all while balancing
marriage and motherhood like a pro ah
well that was that's always the goal I
always want to be great at anything I do
before jetting off to London she posted
these sweet family pics with her husband
Kenneth Petty and their one-year-old son
who she affectionately calls Papa Bear
come on
Nikki's little boy is growing up fast
and despite her busy work schedule she
always finds time to soak up Papa's cute
milestones
say me and Mama laughed at that
say hi
[Music]
thank you